now the Outlook of our water or lack
thereof is a huge concern leaders from
around the valley gathered today to
address water concerns from home and
business owners 8 news now reporter
Brian will explains what the future of
our water may look like you see Lake
Mead and shorelines dwindling you
automatically assume that that Las Vegas
is being Reckless with the water or but
that just couldn't be farther from the
truth Tina Quigley with the Las Vegas
global economic Alliance on the
four-member panel took questions from
community members on the current water
issues facing Nevada as of the
Innovation and the conservation we are
the most secure Dave Johnson with the
water district explaining how Southern
Nevada is ahead of the game on
conserving we're extremely aggressive
with respect to leaks and have
maintained less than five percent of
Lincoln our community has done a
fantastic job with respect to doing the
hard things that are necessary for uh
the concert conservation purposes
programs like like a voluntary removal
of turf and now going into
other programs for the reduction on
evaporative cooling Sarah Price with the
Colorado River commission there's an
advantage I believe to Southern Nevada
because we do not use our water for AG
use as for the Biden administrations of
recent proposals for the Colorado one
would favor California and require big
cuts from Arizona and Nevada another
option would cut the same percentage of
water use from all three states and
another would take no action and risk
Deadpool I think it's important to
understand that it's a draft these are
not fixed Alternatives they were
presented as a series of alternatives to
be considered that's just going to help
to drive people even more so to the
table and collaborate maybe to even a
different level to come up with a
solution that works for for the basin